i challenge anybody watching this watch
the 2001 world series between arizona
diamondbacks and new york yankees
baseball can't get better than that it's
a fun game there's something happening
on everyone why though because there's
action there's activity and there's a
lot of what else is there i mean it's so
much like there's also steroids yeah
steroids exactly i think there should be
baseball do you think it should be legal
steroids in baseball it's not hurting
anybody they're hitting a [ __ ] ball
yeah i want to see the guys juice to the
[ __ ] max cranking home runs listen
having a little personality did anybody
get mad at brad pitt for being juiced to
the hilt and troy having 19 abs yeah
they're not hurting anybody it's
basically
legalized steroids let me tell you let
me tell you what
what are your thoughts on that do you
have an opposing argument so you're just
encouraging give us your argument that's
the argument
arnold schwarzenegger
we had an entire conversation
last podcast about drugs about pills and
about cocaine and i'm like look
marijuana ain't that bad
now we're like shoot up
throw some random [ __ ] there's a
difference there's a difference what a
big difference i give you the big
difference i'll give you the big
difference okay so in 200
2001 2001 morgan stanley 911 2001 i go
to uh mr olympia okay
i'm in shape
i'm ready i'm thinking about going into
the world to compete right it's either
gonna be i'm gonna go be a stock broker
with morgan stanley dean witter i'm
gonna go be a bodybuilder i go to mr
olympia oh but this is real you actually
competed yeah you know i'm sorry no no
no never never happened
yeah i was but this is in the army i was
competing so that's cool so i go into i
go to mr olympia so i'm like i'm gonna
find out what this life looks like okay
so i walk around and i start hanging out
with these guys we start partying and
some of the big names at the time they
you know if you follow bodybuilding you
know these names i've interviewed mostly
i'm going to rip them off for you or no
no no the name's off if you want
you would get the name oh yeah you'd get
the name yeah cormier was a party guy
aaron baker all these guys right so
anyway so i go and i say so
tell me what it takes to be mr olympia
okay the guy says you want to be mr
olympia he says yeah i said i won't know
what it takes i don't want to be a mr
olympia competitor
and he also went to university of
colorado
so let me go back to this so
i'm looking at this guy i'm like listen
i want to kind of be mr olympia and if
i'm going to do this i'm not doing it to
compete i want to be the mr olympia says
okay let me explain to what what we take
let me make the list okay
this this this this this this this this
i won't give the name of who was but we
went through the whole list of things
you need to take this page is long then
four
your
five you're gonna be off season 350
and no one has ever won mr olympia at
six four six five the tallest guy that
won it was six two and a half 235 245
his name is arnold during the days where
bodybuilding was very different now now
they're all five nines ronnie coleman
won it he was like five uh nine five ten
three ten three hundred nine yeah ronnie
coleman's maybe five ten five
hundred percent
phil's five nine right yeah but ronnie
looks bigger no no no to your point i
would tell people this all the time you
know when i was coaching but let me know
let me finish my point the point is the
following here
if you're going to go at that level like
you look at lebron you think lebron just
takes cretan i don't know about that you
look at lebron
you
know wink it's all good
season what percentage of nba players
you think are smoking wheat
probably all of them 80 plus percent
yeah okay so but they're not like it i
agree it's less harmful than steroids
no but there's a there's a return
there's a return
there's a big difference between weed
cocaine lsd special k you know there's a
very you know
between that and
steroids there's a very big difference
there okay
meaning barry okay juan gonzalez used to
be like this right he came in he was
hitting 40 home runs then he started
juicing right then he wasn't hitting the
way he was hitting before it actually
didn't help him as much right some of
the guys because it's good to be like
this sometimes it widens up a little bit
it doesn't work for everybody right
pictures you're doing it more for your
shoulders your elbows recovery that's
more so it's not like you're doing it
like roger clemens wasn't benching six
plates and you know wanting to go
compete roger clemens was recovering
faster having 21 game seasons yeah
and why do you think lebron's playing so
long at such a high level yeah are you
thinking
but bring that back to baseball you're
saying hey go at it do steroids bro it's
a libertarian concept the only thing is
like for me if weed is legal
you got to look at that steroid same
similar kind of a conversation i see
steroids in a similar kind of a
conversation
i see it as a similar type of a
conversation
you choose to
you choose to put it in your body what
is performance in hand let me give you a
different perspective right like that
term performs a handstand like [ __ ] used
to drive me out of my mind i never took
steroids but i did everything possible
within the rules to mimic the effect of
stember steroids we all didn't test the
north texas
everything everything so i'm taking so
instead of taking one clean shot from a
doctor i'm taking 15 freaking seven cato
dheas and then another like t-bomb and
an android
physicist over there but this is what's
happening right like year one that's
legal year two that stuff's illegal i
never broke any rules was i perform
enhancing drugs like it's it's this it's
such a mockery and now my body's like a
bunch of melted crayons because i
completely turned my metabolism off
baseball nobody's getting hurt either
you're hitting the ball so you guys are
all on the same page steroids basically
professional this is the truth the
biggest mistake i ever made in the minor
leagues was not taking steroids the
biggest mistake i ever made because once
you're there your job is to make as much
money for your family as you possibly
might my logic behind this is
if
if it's something you're going to do to
advance
like there is a way that you're
advancing you can consider it if there
is for some people it doesn't work out
well for some people it does what are
the side effects by the way by the way
you actually do what that but that's a
great question but that's a great
question because it's illegal kids are
taking things that they shouldn't take
in quantities they shouldn't take it if
it was legal and your team doctor was
able to administer it the side effects
are negligible so you're saying if the
doctor
the larger point as far as side effects
in in those grown men probably not much
but they're not growing a third testicle
having heart issues like you're actually
saying steroids aren't that bad for you
no not at all all right like can we get
some freaking steroids in there i got to
step out
the problem the problem you can run into
is if you know we have kids so if you
have a 12 year old kid who idolizes you
know uh his favorite baseball player
ryan braun or some [ __ ] like that he's
on steroids well that's going to
encourage that kid to do so at a young
age yeah so if they do it in high school
and like middle school that's where it
gets well just like in the basketball
players do you remember any kids in high
school that were on steroids
i remember yeah it's a little awkward
yeah by the way it was very awkward yeah
so awkward yeah very
yeah
and you're a female yeah
now the greatest swimmer in the world
though that's it you know you didn't
tell me no no no no i don't i'm telling
a whole different story with the college
yeah yeah yeah
but again you talk about the lance
armstrong got caught and they they
paraded him around like a pariah and
then so should he be able to do this
this is the thing he came riding a bike
okay so you're good to go yes you're on
a [ __ ] time okay how about
who should not be able to do steroids i
know uh nfl and ufc i know why nfl
because you're physically hurting each
other so if that steroids allows him to
go zero to you know 40 yard dash faster
he's physically inflicting more unless
everybody's on the same unless everybody
has access to individuals
i believe the last tour de france where
lance armstrong got caught taking
steroids you have to go down the 15th
place to find a guy who didn't
think it was 24th maybe
24 that they would use it that did not
test positive the the 2 through like 20
all have been caught doing steroids so
lance was a scapegoat is what you're
saying the whole team was friends with
lance's thing he was an [ __ ] so
that's why they went after so really
yeah by the way this goes to another
name barry bonds okay similar to barry
another [ __ ] another [ __ ] right i
mean that's nobody wants to see those
guys win
no matter what what about sami sosa
should be in the hall of fame and the
steroids turn him white
yeah did you see that oh that wasn't
that was that was the bleach okay my
best might be a lotion maybe a little
yeah not enough time in the sun maybe
yeah yeah
weird what's going on there a little
salmon salsa now
yeah
66 home runs that one season 90. i don't
know if you've seen the documentary
i was in the military we had a great
time why are sosa home runners i don't
even like baseball
fans
the fact that bud selig is in the hall
of fame after he destroyed the game in
95 and then turned a blind eye to
everything yeah those guys everything
yeah but you have kids right try and get
him to watch baseball my son's like get
the [ __ ] out of here your son's wife
yeah he's like what the [ __ ] is this
your son's five it goes dog's like that
yeah
but he's tough hey dad what is this
[ __ ]
fortnite just nothing but video game so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]